Image on screen: OzPlayer Logo
Text on screen: What is web accessibility and how does it translate to online videos?
Text on screen: Why aren't the current video players accessible?
Text on screen: How do inaccessible videos impact end users?
Text on screen: 1) Keyboard traps
Text on screen: 2) Keyboard inaccessibility
Text on screen: 3) Starting automatically
Text on screen: How is OzPlayer different from other video players?
Text on screen: What other issues make video players inaccessible?
Text on screen: There are more features in development
Text on screen: What features would you like to see?
Image on screen: Epic Photograpy & Video logo and URL, www.epicphotography.com.au, hello@epicphotography.com.au
Text on screen: Directed by Charlotte Brentnall and Mark Fitzgerald
Editing by Mark Fitzgerald
Filmed by Mark Fitzgerald
Starring Gian Wild
Written by Charlotte Brentnall and Gian Wild
Image on screen: OzPlayer logo